y vamos con las noticias de la economía
esta noche con jorge hurtado en directo
américa jorge buenas noches para usted
para noches angela que tal bien bien
mejor heiko en el saludo vamos a entrar
en materia primero con la comparecencia
que hizo el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski en la apertura de la
bolsa de valores de nueva york aunque la
idea es que la campana de apertura de la
bolsa de nueva york sonó entre aplausos
tras la conclusión de sus declaraciones
selenski básicamente pidió inversión en
su país que lucha por recuperar el
territorio ocupado por las fuerzas rusas
se cumplen ya seis meses y medio desde
el inicio de la invasión que ha dejado
más de siete millones de desplazados
según ucrania necesitaría al menos 750
mil millones de dólares para
reconstruirse tras esta guerra
escuchemos y parte de la intervención de
selenski en la bolsa de nueva york
y
estamos reconstruyendo nuestra economía
les damos a ustedes ya sus empresas la
oportunidad de trabajar junto a nosotros
en beneficio de todos ucrania es una
historia de una victoria futura y una
oportunidad para que ustedes inviertan
ahora en proyectos por valor de cientos
de miles de millones de dólares para
compartir la victoria con nosotros
cuidados y entretanto jorge la primera
ministra británica le instruye ya nombró
su nuevo ministro de economía y usted
nos va a contar quién es se trata de
cuasi quantín es un aliado ideológico de
trozo asegura que el gobierno puede
pedir más préstamos para financiar las
ayudas a los hogares y las empresas en
sus facturas de energía que es uno de
los principales problemas en este
momento en reino unido el funcionario
era ministro de empresa y energía y
también trabajó en el ministerio del
brics es que igual es un admirador de la
ex primera ministra margaret thatcher
aunque demostró cierto pragmatismo a la
hora de aplicar esos principios en sus
trabajos anteriores en el gobierno
y cambiando a otro tema de eeuu se
prepara para invertir en 50.000 millones
de dólares en la industria de microchips
muy preciados por estos días sin duda
alguna bueno los fondos de ayuda federal
fueron anunciados por la secretaria de
comercio de eeuu china reimond o los
suministros de semiconductores se vieron
afectados por los confinamientos y
cierres de fábricas que se extendieron
por el mundo en 2020 cuando llegó la
pandemia del cobi 19 esa escasez provocó
una ralentización de la fabricación
mundial de vehículos y dispositivos
tecnológicos actualmente taiwán tiene el
85 por ciento del mercado mundial de
semiconductores algunos estudios apuntan
a que una interrupción solamente de un
día en la producción de esa industria
puede tener un impacto de 67 mil
millones de dólares en el mundo aunque
corea del sur y taiwán dominen el
mercado china ha ganado terreno desde la
pandemia y actualmente se acerca al 10
por ciento de la cuota de mercado algo
que eeuu ve como una amenaza por ejemplo
para américa latina el salvador cumple
un año desde la adopción es del bitcoin
esta decisión de tan polémica del equipo
que le bueno la cripta moneda se
convirtió básicamente en la principal
apuesta económica del presidente bucl en
estos 12 meses el gobierno salvadoreño
anunció la compra de 2.381 bitcoin por
más de 100 millones de dólares lanzó una
billetera digital anunció la
construcción de la bit coincidí y la
colocación de mil millones de dólares en
bonos respaldados por la cripto moneda
pero todo se ha hecho o se ha manejado
de forma o casi en secreto para algunos
expertos la apuesta no ha tenido éxito
el banco central de la reserva espera
cerrar el 2022 con un crecimiento
económico del 2,3 por ciento tasa que
está en el rango registrado desde hace
décadas en el salvador un estudio de
varios economic research plantea que
únicamente el 20 por ciento de la
población usa la billetera gubernamental
y según datos oficiales menos del 2 por
ciento de las remesas que llegan a ese
país se hacen a través de las billeteras
digitales cuando el salvador hizo el
bitcoin su moneda oficial el precio
rondaba los 45 mil dólares por bitcoin
ahora se ubica en 20 mil dólares
aproximadamente y según la agencia
calificadora moody's el plan de buque
les ha costado a cerca de ese país unos
375 millones de dólares más que
cuestionable en otras noticias apolo no
podría vender su iphone sin cargadores
en brasil porque es una noticia curiosa
el gobierno salvadoreño acusa a la
empresa el gobierno brasileño para una
cosa la empresa por venta de productos
incompletos discriminación contra el
consumidor y transferencia de
responsabilidad tercero la medida tomada
por el departamento de protección y
defensa del consumidor anula los
permisos de venta de todos los modelos
de iphone 12 y 13 apple deberá también
pagar una multa de cerca de 25 millones
de dólares según la empresa la decisión
de no suministrar o vender los
cargadores junto con los teléfonos
responde a un compromiso ambiental algo
que cuestiona este departamento de
defensa del consumidor en brasil vaya
pero así funciona por en todo el mundo y
jorge por favor la cifra es 10 75 por
ciento en esa cifra se sitúa la tasa de
interés referencial en chile la cifra es
sobre lo esperado por el mercado y es
parte de su estrategia para
contrarrestar la presión inflacionaria
que vive no solamente chile sino muchos
países en el mundo
pues así llegamos al final de este
segmento gracias a ustedes jorge y lo
dejo porque vamos con el debate
[Música]